e a criatividade é um mito sim a
criatividade é o maior mito da
humanidade se imaginar dá 20 ali parado
pensando e de repente pa surge uma ideia
o sfumato ele tá pintando e venha
Monalisa eu não consigo imaginar a dona
Cleusa ali na casa dela com a família
dela passando necessidade e precisamos
se Reinventar e daí ela fala vou tomar
uma xícara de chá para ter meu momento
Eureka e daí ela tem uma ideia que vai
salvar a história da vida dela e da
família dela e vai começar a vender bolo
ser uma baita empreendedora a
criatividade nada mais é do que um
exercício na busca de solução de
problemas você não acorda criativo você
não lá se criativo a criatividade tem
que ser exercitadas ela tem que ser
adestrada para mim a criatividade é suor
lágrima sangue
se for a criatividade é você conseguir
sobreviver diante de qualquer tipo de
dificuldade e obstáculos que a vida vai
te passar eu nunca me vi criativa
Acredite Eu me formei na faculdade da
cidade propaganda e quando eu entrei na
faculdade eu falei meu deus o que que eu
tô fazendo aqui Eu não sou criativa
nunca tive uma grande ideia é uma ideia
genial e geralmente a gente pensa dessa
forma né a gente acha que a criatividade
é fadada apenas as grandes mentes mas
não eu também pensava dessa forma e
comecei a entender no decorrer da minha
vida que a criatividade não é apenas
para os gêmeos que aconteceu uma coisa
engraçada comigo há um tempo atrás eu
estava no evento e o rapaz veio até a
mim e perguntou o que que eu fazia eu
falei tem uma empresa de Publicidade
propaganda e na mesma hora ele falou
Nossa você deve ter escolhido essa área
por ser muito criativa
o e naquele momento eu pensei respondo
ou não respondo esse preço lhe falei
olha na verdade eu nunca imaginei que
poderia ser criativo algum dia e eu sei
que muitas pessoas pensam como aquele
cara eu levei anos para entender isso
principalmente porque eu tive um pai
muito Severo na minha infância eu nunca
pude me expressar nunca pude falar meu
pai não me deixava a fazer absolutamente
nada que tinha que seguir as regras ali
à risca e se eu falasse alguma coisa ou
me estressar se eu era exposta eu
poderia até repente apanhar por motivo
nenhum então eu cresci aprendendo que eu
não posso falhar que eu tenho que ser
assertiva que eu tenho que fazer as
coisas o mais certas possíveis não podia
errar eu cresci sem nunca poder dar
minha opinião ou expor um ponto de vista
de uma maneira tranquila e quando eu
falo que eu tive um pai Severo é porque
ele era muito você vieram mesmo para
você ter uma ideia na minha infância
eu viajava e a gente é muito para o sul
porque a família dele é de lá a gente
percorrer todo o caminho no carro eu sem
poder falar absolutamente nada não podia
falar nada entendeu eu terminar os
momentos né Eu queria fazer xixi 800km
eu queria parar ele no banheiro e eu não
podia me estressar não podia falar não
tinha que encontrar uma saída porque com
10 anos de idade 11 anos de idade usar
fralda não era uma opção para mim então
eu ficava buscando ideias para conseguir
fazer com que ele parasse o carro para a
gente poder ir ao banheiro e daí eu fui
pensando e consegui usar uma estratégia
eu ia no cantinho do banco perto da
minha mãe bem no vida dela bem baixinho
e falava para ela sem ele perceber que
eu queria parar e daí ela com calma
falava que ela gostaria de parar Então
que a gente conseguiu fazer essa parada
eu era apenas uma criança mas hoje eu
estava sendo programada para buscar as
saídas criativas para determinar os
problemas você sabe né talvez você já
tenha sonhado aí para Disney
o sonho de boa parte das pessoas né a
gente pode ter 10 20 30 anos 60 anos a
gente tem o sonho de conhecer aquela
Terra Mágica e eu quando fui a primeira
vez que Estados Unidos Claro escolher a
Disney mas quando a gente faz uma viagem
para fora do país a primeira coisa que
vem na nossa cabeça é a língua local
principalmente se a gente não sabe falar
a língua daquele país e eu
Definitivamente não sabia falar inglês
naquela época então o máximo conseguia
falar era Hi my name is Carol falar meu
tipo nada eu sabia falar nada mas isso
não reparável não me paralisava para
poder percorrer os meus sonhos então aos
25 anos eu e meu marido e mais um casal
de amigos fomos pro dizem piercing eu
posso dizer que foi realmente um sonho
aquela viagem mas no final da viagem se
tornar um pesadelo a gente estava indo
para o porto para poder voltar para o
Brasil e de repente a gente
Oi e o pior a gente estava com horário
bem apertado e naquele Desespero de
conseguir encontrar o aeroporto certo e
consegui chegar a gente olhou no papel
com o horário do voo e Vimos que
tínhamos olhada inclusive vai dar errado
então a gente estava duplamente atrasado
corremos o máximo que a gente pode
chegando no aeroporto a gente chegou era
dez para as duas e o vou sair as duas
horas da tarde então vamos correndo
fazer o check-in e quando atendente nos
viu ela simplesmente falou impossível
vocês poderem sair né nesse voo porque
aeronave de vocês já está na pista de
decolagem nessa hora do desespero tomou
conta da gente estamos pensando o que a
gente vai fazer porque além de tudo a
gente não tinha mais dinheiro tava no
fim da viagem o máximo que a gente tinha
era $20 na carteira então naquele
momento sem saber falar inglês eu
comecei a pensar como que eu posso
resolver esse problema como que eu posso
resolver esse conflito
Eu queria conversar em consegui me
comunicar com ela com palavras porque eu
não sabia inglês que eu pensei que eu
sou comunicativa e expressiva vou me
comunicar assim e foi ali com todo o meu
jeitinho com uma cara de tristeza
profunda tristeza e de muito desespero
tentar explicar para ela o que tinha
acontecido e ver se havia uma
possibilidade de conseguir vou para nós
sem custo mais eu soubesse que seria
quase impossível isso mas não custa
tentar né E daí ela começou uma certa
empatia por nós pelo nosso desespero ali
entrou em contato com o supervisor dela
pegou o telefone e começou a conversar
com ele ali a gente não tava entendendo
nada ficamos aguardando né aqueles
minutos que ela estava na telefone para
nós pareciam horas né intermináveis e
quando ela desligou o telefone depois de
muito tempo depois de várias Idas e
Vindas Ela mostrou a tela para gente do
computador dela onde ela tinha
conseguido as quatro passar
e sem custo algum a gente não falou
absolutamente nada para voltar para o
Brasil no dia seguinte já estávamos
voltando e chegando são e salvo e para
mim esse é um grande case de uma forma
de você enxergar o problema e buscar
soluções criativas com menor Impacto
possível e muitas vezes quando a gente
tem um problema como esse desespero a
gente realmente se paralisa se desespera
e deixa as emoções tomar conta da gente
e acaba não conseguindo ter ideias
porque a gente fica totalmente fechado
com aquele sentimento de medo de
desespero mesmo mas quando a gente tem
essa forma de olhar de uma maneira
diferente para um problema para uma
crise as ideias Começam a surgir tem uma
história muito interessante numa das
empresas que eu tive a gente tinha um
problema a gente não tinha dinheiro
nenhum aquela época passava uma situação
bem crítica financeiramente Então tudo
ali era bem controlar Dinho existe uma
sala é enxuta onde still uma mesa de
corte
O que é essa mesmo que estava quase a
sala toda e a gente precisava dobrar a
produção dela só que com uma mesa só não
dava a gente precisava ter duas mesas
menores a gente não tinha dinheiro para
comprar duas mesas EA gente começou a
pensar a gente pode vender essa mesa
comprar duas ainda assim não vai dar o
curso quando você vende você não
consegue né ter o valor ali igual né o
valor bom para conseguir comprar as duas
As duas vezes e começamos a pensar a
pensar aquela mesa que a gente tinha
mesa grande era um sonho de consumo e
daí eu tive uma ideia eu falei gente a
gente cortar mais ao meio e
transformá-la em duas a gente tem alguns
pedaços de madeira que daria para fazer
os pés e a gente vê se eu conseguiria
cortar e naquele momento toda equipe
fosse louca na louca não vamos acabar
com essa mesa linda e depois de muita
conversa o boot xaveco eles entenderam e
comprar a minha ideia a gente cortou a
mesa EA gente conseguiu dobrar a
produção sem aumentar um real de que
e sem gastar com absolutamente nada isso
sim é o poder da criatividade em meio ao
caos e eu longo da minha vida eu iria
assim e forma totalmente intuitiva sendo
criativa no mundo que cada vez mais
complexo e os poucos eu fui entendendo
que a criatividade era o meu maior
combustível e que a criatividade não era
para ser para grandes mentes mas sim
para a gente poder resolver problemas a
Qualquer Custo ou muitas vezes se
possível sem custo algum meu marido
brincava comigo quando a gente se
conheceu lá atrás que eu era rica mais
pobre que ele conhecia isso porque eu
morava numa casa muito legal no
condomínio mas eu não tinha muita coisa
na verdade eu tinha o básico e quando eu
falo base quero básico mesmo um Danone
para o meu pai já era uma coisa que não
precisava ser comprada era bobeira sabe
mas eu queria as coisas eu queria e eu
fiquei pensando o que que eu vou fazer
da minha vida foi quando eu me vi dentro
de um ônibus saindo de Itu interior de
São
tô indo para capital sozinha com 16 anos
para comprar bijuteria na 25 de Março e
revender na escola porque mais legal
daquilo para vender mas foi Meu Grito de
liberdade foi Libertador para mim e
aquilo me fez abrir minha mente para
outras milhares de possibilidades e sem
o perceber eu estava destrando meu
cérebro para grandes coisas que
aconteceu na minha vida e como eu
consegui usar a criatividade para
resolver ela só que nessa hora a gente
não percebe isso a gente tem de olhar a
foto e não o filme e quando eu entendi
isso eu percebi que com a criatividade
eu podia lidar com qualquer crise seja
familiar seja emocional seja financeira
seja Empresarial qualquer crise mas você
deve tá pensando né Mas Carol como que
você conseguiu né você que sempre foi
podada né Sempre foi ali repreendido
desde a infância Como que você conseguiu
lidar aí para não ter mais um
se calhar o medo de errar e consegui ser
essa pessoa criativa essa pessoa que tem
a mente aberta para pensar em
possibilidades eu vou te contar uma
coisa existe um segredo para gente
buscar a criatividade a gente abrir a
porta para ele criatividade e esse
segredo é um I se o ICI ele é uma porta
gigantesca de opções que a gente pode
abrir a nossa mente sabe são
possibilidades então você não precisa
pensar se às vezes é uma ideia maluca
uma ideia impossível de ser feita você
tem que simplesmente deixar fluir as
possibilidades na sua mente e é mágico
porque começa a surgir ideias quando a
gente tá aberto para os se a gente não
se preocupa se algo impossível algo
muito louco a gente não se preocupa se
Será que dá para cortar aquela mesa ao
meio simplesmente as ideias vem e o
resultado é muito melhor o próprio
Einstein fala que a imaginação é mais
importante que o conhecimento e olha só
a criação de um custa nada então deixe
realmente fluir as ideias dentro de você
e faça com que isso mude a realidade do
seu problema a realidade daquele
obstáculo que tá acontecendo na sua vida
diante de um problema diante da crise
diante do Caos pense esse se eu ir por
esse caminho se eu resolver dessa forma
se a gente fica daquele jeito se eu
pensar numa forma de me expressar mesmo
assim que sabia falar a língua naquele
naquele aeroporto para poder conseguir
passagem sem custo algum Afinal ou não a
gente já tem para tudo né então vamos
atrás do SIM das possibilidades e a
mágico porque as ideias vêm lembra da
minha história com meu pai eu poderia
simplesmente passar minha vida inteira
com medo de falhar e não deixar as
ideias fluírem dentro de mim mas a gente
tem o poder de reprogramar o nosso
inconsciente tem um problema tem um
obstáculo tem fora da Caixa
é bem simples isso que a vida pode tirar
e reprograme seu cérebro a realmente
pensar em alternativas diferentes para
determinados problemas foi assim que eu
a deixarei o meu cérebro e foi assim que
eu descobri que a criatividade é um
estado de ser e que não é algo limitado
a apenas um por cento da população hoje
eu lidera uma equipe de pessoas com
mentes Geniais também tem um projeto
chegou a pouco de gênero sua entrevistas
com mulheres empreendedoras de todo o
Brasil e incrível poder conversar com
elas o que eu mais gosto de conversar
com elas é por entender como que elas
lidam com os diversos problemas que elas
têm com as diversas dificuldades com as
crises de forma criativa e isso me
profecia até a pensar em mais formas
criativas para os meus problemas e esse
projeto só aconteceu porque eu deixei
incluir vários esses para aí sim
conseguir chegar essa ideia nesse
formato do projeto papo de génio e eu
quero ouvir realizar nossa conversa
contando a história de como que eu fui
com
a prestar aqui hoje era uma quarta-feira
à noite eu recebi a ligação da curadoria
do Sedex no início e quando recebi
aquela ligação foi para receber o
convite para palestrar não mesmo eu
muito feliz com convite aceitei e eles
comentaram né que seria aerotex Uniso
vai ser esse é o nome do evento combinei
com eles ok na hora que eu desliguei o
telefone eu falei com meu marido amor o
evento na Uniso tem o mesmo nome que
aquelas palestras que a gente assistindo
Ted Sedex deu Rafa olhou para mim e
falou tem que ser um nome parecido né
coincidência foi É deve ser no dia
seguinte quando eu recebi a carta o
e-mail né com a carta no topo dessa
carta tava logo do t-rex e quando eu vi
isso Eu quase caí da cadeira liguei na
mesma hora com raiva falei Rafa não
evento com o nome tipo de Dex é o
próprio
e naquele momento a euforia tomou conta
de mim que ainda mais feliz e
conversando com a curadoria do Sedex
Uniso eu perguntei qual é seu tema o quê
que vocês querem que eu falho e eles
falaram Carol fale sobre a criatividade
na 15 e quando eu vi aquele tema eu
falei legal fichinha já passei por
tantas crises da minha vida todos os
tipos de crises possíveis Vai ser
tranquilo falar desse tema vou querer
fazer o meu melhor para conseguir fazer
um conteúdo que agregue para quem for
assistir e passaram-se alguns dias eu
pensando nesse conteúdo e eu falei meu
deus o que que eu vou falar não venha
nada meu corpo foi tomado por medo por
desespero e eu realmente estava ali
preocupada com que eu ia trazer o medo
tomou conta de mim e daí foi quando eu
pensei o maior problema da criatividade
não é a gente acha que a criativo e a
gente
a ser criativo e nesse momento eu amei
meus pensamentos acalmem os sentimentos
e pensei em vários esses de
possibilidades para poder conversar aqui
com vocês e quando eu consegui fazer
isso simplesmente as ideias começaram a
fluir com a mesma intensidade com a
mesma beleza que uma água cai de uma
cachoeira e hoje eu faço um convite a
você e se você começar a pensar na
criatividade de uma forma diferente
obrigada